[Music]
what's up guys i see people in there
where are they at
it don't start to
tell two
what you mean where are we at i was
sleeping
i literally just woke up like 15 minutes
ago
if that
so i'm still a little bit waking up i
don't know if uh
any of us will be on camera today
because uh i'm coming in hot man i'm
coming in hot
so where does the chat want to watch
this today do we want to watch it on
twitch or youtube
some feedback why don't you
twitch your youtube
alexander you can't tell me what to do
i'll go to sleep during this show
you don't know me like that
i'm still technically waking up at the
moment
see
what's funny
is
[Music]
we're sitting here on this uh this
youtube thing
i didn't even want to
log into the iop account because he like
we had a separate account we log into
for uh to do the podcast on
i didn't feel like doing that so i was
like i'm gonna just go with the addict
template i don't care
i think
the best place for no lag is twitch guys
i know some of you don't like twitch
i'm not the biggest fan of twitch to be
honest with you either but i think the
best place to watch it as to which
that's what i'm saying now alexander
it's it's pretty consistent
we want consistency these days
uh
let me look
look like it just might be me
and king
well there's a couple other people
that
it that might be showing up but
they got jobs and stuff i already worked
today
oh it's been a long day man been a long
day guys
uh let me put on the intro music
i'm still waking up man waiting for king
to show up
guys gotta bear with me guys gotta bear
with me
where's the power the the powder ranger
cog
he's on his way to florida
for the uh for guardian car or whatever
they call it these days ddx
gdc
abc i don't know what it's called
it's the destiny place man it's the
destiny place
[Music]
what do you guys talk about some last of
us remake they announced the last of his
roommates
i'm a little behind man
you guys got to work with me
so we'll probably go to twitch today to
be honest with you guys
[Music]
i just don't want to have a situation
where king is ahead of me because he's
on twitch or youtube
wow
well
i kind of figured it'd be 70 dollars
[Music]
yeah king's coming
and i'll be back guys
[Music]
so
king is not here yet but he'll be here
momentarily
he's about to join
no it's not a sub it's not an indie
showcase i don't know what they're gonna
show
[Music]
what's up uh audio is on by the way
they can hear you
while now
all right people tell me
how
the um
the mixture between
jeff talking and and us
we're on twitch by the way
and this is summer game fest a live
showcase of what's next in the wide wide
world of video games we are live here in
los angeles and whether you're streaming
from home or watching inside an imax
theater welcome to our showcase event
over the next few hours we'll give you
updates on the games you love be joined
by special developer guests and yes have
a few surprises along the way too now
what i love about this show is that it's
a true cross industry showcase whether
you play on xbox pc playstation switch
or mobile we'll have games for you it
doesn't matter your platform of choice
we're all here to come together as one
community that simply loves the art of
amazing video games
the biggest franchises in the industry
are here like call of duty you'll get
introduced to exciting
independent developers who we think
deserve the spotlight too if we do this
right hopefully you'll discover a few
new games to put on your wish list and
even if you don't get every announcement
that you desire let's face it
everything today but we've got a lot of
great stuff so let's get started
over 30 years ago capcom street fighter
hit arcades and ever since this
legendary japanese fighting game series
has continued to evolve street fighter 6
is coming in 2023 and right now we're
excited to officially confirm a
character coming to the game and show
you the exclusive first gameplay footage
enjoy
[Music]
let's get this mission started
oh
yo it used to be a whatchamacallit back
in the day um like a broken arcade it
was like a modder
and you thought like
i'm just on another level
you can tell i know literally nothing
about this fighting game i hear you but
it's all about the code
next it's time for a brand new game
announcement here at summer game fest
check this out
brand new game king
yep
i'm trying to bring up our chat focus
entertainment
sergeant leo alvarez of the cmle recon
squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
base locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online
we found the relay
but there was a
problem
get that door closed now private this
looks like kojima
close that door
take the lead
this is focus entertainment
oh
this ain't good
what we found was
a new kind of evil didn't we watch we
went to focus we did focus boo for
wheezing packs right
yeah
okay then this is something that we saw
this
wasn't human
hmm
yeah this is the aliens what's my polar
this is probably dlc for the aliens
the space marine alien space marine
yeah
yeah this is probably dlc for that
again it was pretty fun it just never
took off and i don't understand why
um
like the co-op the cooperative uh
those games aren't taking off you know
when left to death was so good i don't
know
i don't know what i saw in there
nonsense you know what you saw i know
when i
and someone needs to know
ultimate killing machine
so then it's not the same thing okay
this is different oh is it a three
a three fourth oh that looks pretty
decent it's cross gen though so
next two years ago at the game awards we
revealed the callisto protocol from the
creative forces behind the dead space
franchise today i am thrilled to get the
world this is the first raw game play
alongside its creator glenn schofield
but first here's the quote-unquote
scofield cut of the brand new trailer
with a little more gore
[Music]
than what we saw before
she going for a shock value j
g
this is only next-gen right
i don't know
no wait i think they cut out the xbox
one and they're gonna be using the cloud
since they already know about that and
this is on playstation
4 is holding us back yet again oh my god
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of there well they
need something to play since
shout out to me
right there
that's your old life
you got to let that go
in my hands this is my gonna be lit up
i'm just trying to give you a chance
put that eggs down
oh my god
they took away his good parts
no wonder he's angry
that they look crazy they gave me herpes
it took away my good parts
say you know tina too
oh my god you have uh stds the festival
oh my god
imagine how quick
gives me chills every time quick
pregnancy rates will go down turned into
that
easy
it's very easy
you know the sad part there's a chance
you turn into that and people still be
out there doing it
oh my god
yeah you got more going jay
oh he bit his whole head off
yeah
welcome
to your new home
yeah man i feel like there's only like
15 maybe 10 more seconds on that trailer
yeah but more more gordo definitely for
real
digital deluxe more gore version
that's right we know what you wanted to
see and joining me now glen schofield oh
god they're doing the talking thing
first of all yeah you know what you got
to do you got to shoot it looks
absolutely incredible
the fact that you have built this team i
love his stage i love how he builds his
stuff
blows me away so congratulations yeah
thanks man uh
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second
you know i want to thank you uh for all
you've done for the game industry uh all
these years man i i think i've known you
like 16 17 years now and uh
um you've been an ambassador thank you
i'm getting that back new game
at one point in time
i just like jason
you know what i'm saying thank you not
about me it's about you guys
yeah it's so fun to do these shows and
to show this game so people saw the
trailer but what i'm so excited
man is it you just brought a raw
gameplay sequence this game is in
development and i can't be blown away
tell us a bit about what are we going to
see today yeah we got a couple minutes
of uh like you said like we're all game
play um it's two segments in the first
half of the game uh one is the med bay
another one is a power station and
you're gonna see is that part of the
paid demo that's going to be on these
consoles later
just about everything
yeah it probably is a weapon called the
grip you only get a chance to play the
med bay picks up the enemies
4.99 rips them apart it's great and uh
and then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh are you telling us the ending of
the game
i i want to thank no in a trailer like
you said through coving through
everything else i was just realizing i
was like yo is that dude in the
background breathing on his knees
this looks like a world-class next-gen
game uh it's it's rare that teams are
bringing something out like this this
year and i'm just saying let's let the
footage speak for itself at schofield
striking distance here it is first game
play
nice looking church gen game
does that mean some gameplay yeah this
is it now
this is running on the series x
i'm okay with this
capture going
probably got the distribution ps5
probably won't even have these
holographs playing it's just you're just
looking at this
[Music]
they can't have two moving at the same
time
playstation 5 already had none of the
neon lights it's just a dark group
oh
this is very dead spacey
so you should have finished them off
then the big boy showed up
boy
nice
hit him in the belly button see that's
what happens if you shoot king's arm off
he's just still going to come after you
okay you don't even need an arm just
just
put like a a knife to the other arm and
stick a ps5 at the end of it
[Laughter]
you've been watching too much elder
scroll i mean um elder ring
make my arm into a dragon arm
yo this definitely got dead space vibes
all over it
did you see how he put his arm on the
wall
when he got too close to the wall
yeah
i assume that green bar up there's your
health
on his neck yeah
yeah remember on on dead space it was
like
his spine right yeah
did he throw some vomit at him
oh different gun
oh
i don't know what all this stem
so he has some like uh sonic powers
oh
well hello then
oh my god that's what happens when you
guys talk that snap about me on twitter
this october call of duty modern warfare
2 what is he in 8k ward is once again
returning to its roots for a modern day
action game he's on ak on the series x
he's hung he's on 1080p on the ps5 right
now
let's head to the port of long beach to
check in with johannesburg
call of duty
yes
yo you notice that so far with the
market and the call of duty it hasn't
been saying like playstation 28
usher in a new era it's not weird
with the launch of modern warfare 2
we are back
we are bigger and we are bringing the
entire team
price
gas soap alejandra gas is in this one
yeah you moan daily gas this is what's
up beauty in a whole new way he's
bringing the sauce by the world we're
about to enter
hit my man up i didn't know he's in call
of duty staggering odds are just the
beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
ah yo whoever did that
they spent some money boy activision got
that box
yo doesn't this look like
remember metal gear when you get to the
ship
the first time you play metal gear solid
on the playstation
we know this ain't captured on
playstation 4.
be ready for anything
look at the depth of field perception yo
actual we're set
guppy get to work
all of this brought to you by lovely pc
pc master race stand up
oh you heard right it's launching in
steam oh i didn't know that
yeah so you know they got their own
battle on that thing so the the huge
thing is
you know microsoft like we want it
everywhere man
they're doing this quick
look at the shadow
what was the prompt what was the prompt
did you see the prompt was it a pc
prompt
oh it's on the playstation
whoa
playstation 5 up to snuff huh oh
[Music]
is the type of
gameplay i want to see it at xbox or
hell yeah
people getting thrown off the roof let's
get it
look at the water running down the rails
the level of realism is astounding
please don't shoot me while i'm wet
of course
i said you probably came out there to
use the bathroom and that porta potty
got capped right when he got out the
door he shot the boat in the porta poli
bag
oh buddy
you just laid a good one
they know someone's there
nice
it looks good
hell yeah
well i've never seen the play uh um
a call of duty
oh
stick his head out the window man give
him that meat back ah there you go
i love that you can pick up the grenade
and throw it back so that
oh molotov
oh
they moving left to right fast aren't
they yeah yep hell yeah
take it up to the top
yeah i thought that i thought they're
going to lean
clear
you have your orders son stop that
launch
rough seas
you may tell me this entire time they
could have went to the very top but they
didn't
[Music]
your position
once we're on deck we push to the bridge
fast secure those controls stop this
vessel yep how do we board
take the ramp
ooh
we got a two dollar superchat from
shrimp kingdom gas prices are so high
they're still in containers
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile controls are on the bridge
they show you a lot
yeah i actually think they might be
staying over the welcome at this point
so they won't be showing this on
microsoft bro
thank god
i don't have no issue with call of duty
i'm just not a big fan of them i wanted
them to close the show with this just
like this but um
being that it launched the other day on
thursday and
now you're seeing so much of it it will
be redundant
so star field it is
you wanted microsoft to close with this
yeah
just to um double down on the fact that
it's xbox
well not exclusive
[Applause]
check your corners
it does look good
you get killed because of the water
that'll be nice
directional explosive 2
that's all folks
that's right
[Music]
and then the show ends
thank you for tuning in access to the
open beta
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thank you great to
have you with us and also jeff from uh
infinity ward so
we saw the first gameplay thanks for
that extended sequence looks incredible
uh jeff tell us a bit about that mission
uh where is that set in the game what
are we seeing there absolutely so um is
it me we're really excited to welcome
back uh i personally feel like they
spent a lot of time on the gameplay as
uh gary are they about to spend the
exact amount of time
talking about what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters uh
that were you may recognize from this is
the franchise that we're reimagining is
it me or it's kind of a bad show already
like starting out uh soap john mctavish
um and then a couple other new
characters
were really excited that we got to uh
create for this game um first uh
commander philip graves and uh mexican
special forces uh colonel alejandro and
alejandro i gotta say we're it's a
character we're really excited about
he's a guy who's super capable and a guy
who's just as important as test course
but as far as the level's concerned um
you know this i got a shout out to iw
you know this was a tremendous
collaboration across all of the the
different uh disciplines as you saw
everybody coming together some really uh
motivated devs here and uh you know you
saw the the wind and the uh animations
and the awesome sound design and of
course our new water tech which is
actually pushing the boat in different
directions it's creating a physically
dynamic environment allowing for the
cover you were seeing in certain cases
you could be behind cover and then
suddenly that cover would shift and
leave you exposed but it also leaves the
enemy exposed creating this emergent
gameplay um so again i'm i'm very
excited just can't wait that i'm so
excited that we get to show it off today
and that's just a hint of where things
are going to go uh johanna tell us a bit
about call of duty overall modern
warfare 2 obviously you know we're so
excited that it's back this year but
you've got lots going on across holiday
what can we expect from you guys this
year yeah we um first of all thanks for
having us here we're just so excited for
october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment we've got 467
while watching let's get those lights up
incredible graphics all the things just
within the game itself built all on one
shared engine now i think a lot of kings
warzone and i ain't feeling these deep
dives of course i like that stuff i mean
let's let him do it his own experience
you know um
he gets watched from the quality
a ton of ads and stuff like that later
and
you know i love his stage i love the
hard work that he put into it
you know let him build his uh
relationship with the developers and let
them talk and you know come on the stage
it's a great format that he has and
that's fantastic keep that off my stage
as well someone called me someone
calling she's wearing green so it's just
from the community community we love
when the fans can pick up some things um
they look so happy now that they're
working for microsoft but we will get
into the details of war zone 2.0 for
sure it will be an extent we're under a
great regime now before so much tyranny
and
and and heartbreak
i dreaded going to work every day but
microsoft
there's bagels in the break room
yeah that's what i'm saying bone i don't
like
deep dive and long game plays like
together like i feel like that's a bad
man
yeah he's he's squeezing orange all
right we've got lots more summer game
fest still to go and now it's time to
announce a classic pc gaming franchise
is coming back with a sequel over 30
years after its first release i loved
this game when i was growing up so i'm
honored to share this very first look
what you loved
show me what you love joe
30 years later
[Music]
battletoads no
it started buffering
[Music]
out of this world
flashback flashback flash map flashback
2 flashback 2 flashback 2 flashback 2.
all right let's turn back time back in
2017 we announced which fire at the game
awards almost five years later you ain't
aimed for this excited the team at the
astronauts in poland has put together
are you crazy of this dark fantasy first
person shooter which will they said that
was what 30 years ago
oh my god oh my god
they said 30 years ago
shut up
i i'd have been
i i'd have been like three three months
old
oh
well hello
excuse me
[Music]
yes please
yes
that's how i move when i eat when i
drink a red bull
you move like that when you drink a
variable they put more than that in your
red bull son
don't buy from that dealer no more
i don't think he's authorized to sell
what he's selling
bull gives me wings
no i mean literally
yo this looks good
like fable
[Laughter]
turn your fable to a first person
shooter
i'm good on this
i like this
i'm about this stuff right here you saw
the crossbow
i'm about all this nice little flintlock
oh he gave the sign of the cross or
monster right behind them
which fire yeah witch fire bonfire with
fire which fire
early access soon yeah throw that on
your wish list oh
oh i like that that looked nice though
so far jeff on the roof it's an
ambitious new game from a new
independent studio in europe starring
some very familiar names enjoy this
world premiere new game announcement
world premiere
i missed the world premiere noise yeah i
don't like his world from here that's
just supposed to say
black card games kind of racist i can't
believe this song
oh
solace
what's that game um
for the playstation
regulator what is it
what is that game
it's broken and it was uh then they
brought the studio
begins with a r
it's the shooter attic what's the name
of it
the shooter returned to five yeah return
xbox got the sequel
oh my god
and i need to find out what it is
for solace
yes sir
you're not liking this one adam it's
something brandon oh god now we're gonna
talk about it
about it
well i get to play a character named
wyatt taylor's a medical officer who's
stationed at this uh base fort salas
and uh it's the epicenter of this
mystery that we'll discover and uncover
as we go through the game and of course
my character will be at times in
opposition with
roger's character the battle we've been
waiting to see every once in a while
oh man we can't wait to show you what
we've been working on and by the way
jeff this looks awesome man it's so
great to be here thanks for having us
i'm glad somebody complimented him on
that stage because that stage is
definitely definitely one of the first
major ones for a while and i play a
character by the name of jack leary he's
a maintenance engineer on a remote
martian mining post
his job is to make sure that none of the
equipment breaks down while it's on
their graveyard shift the graveyard
shift meaning mars and earth are really
far apart from each other and their
orbits around the sun so help is not a
simple call away
uh i gotta ask i think a lot of people
will see this thing and they'll probably
wonder
you know it's a new team right uh you
know independent studio in europe that's
making this but with huge production
values i'm curious like why does it look
so good look at this tell us a bit about
the background i i will say that 2020 we
sold ourselves you know basically you're
made up
triple a studios and the indie stews of
the triple students they're like the
janitors
uh james tinsdale with this brand new
what we did was we put motion capture
being captured
motion captures
the experience
actually he still might be tied in the
basement of that place right now we got
to go right back
new studio brand new energy and of
course
i get to work with one of the best in
the business and me i get the privilege
who's the other getting to see this guy
and watch him in action i i know i love
to work and i love
jeff what is that velvet there that's
velvet i like the energy like they're
giving out to show you yeah they go i
love see this is the stuff that i like
when i go to packs
super energetic about their game
enthusiastic talking about it feeling
the emotions
we would give them a shirt curves are
always important yeah so we're going to
see i'll give the guy in the back the
shirt later on the other guy in the
front he looks like he won't wear it
because he doesn't want man i'm going to
give the camera a guy he's on a pretty
height thrillers that's what i'm saying
because he's the one who did all the
motion
the camera dude right now traverse which
we're excited to show you oh you still
use it
the narrative is a huge element to this
the they they didn't waste uh any any
resources on the the performance for
sure i got to say one quick story if i
can um no one of our favorites no no
stories man um
there is a lot of action in this game
and that was at the the forefront of
this and to speak to the performance
capture aspect we brought in an
incredible i gotta give a shout out to
nathaniel our stunt coordinator who
walked us through and really approached
us in a completely different way
the story of this fight and so roger and
i sat down we said these are where our
characters are acted like his life
and he walked us through this incredible
fight and i about halfway out halfway
through i started tuning him out and i
was like hey man i just want you know
i've got no ego about this but i can do
a lot of things but i i can't do this
and he grabbed me by my shoulders and he
says oh you can you will and it's going
to be glorious and we did and we did
dance
you got to yell out pause after that
how he was saying that i'm surprised he
didn't walk up to
jeff and grab him and we can
you know
well next up with the space team it's
time
this one is going to grab you and we are
so honored to debut it
what is it another word for major
doing yourself
oh
the hell
hmm
no
someone forgot to have to pay them nah
nope
absolutely not
how you know he's just not doing
maintenance
no
someone
oh hell no nothing
no
no no
that's right yo
why did you just flick off the screen
with her
nothing scarier than the escalator
that's not working i gotta use these
steps
oh you man shimmy you got the shimmy
shimmy y'all it just a creep
he's recording uh what's up with that
though oh oh
you didn't show me your hall pass
buddy
booty
series excellence yes
that looks explosive that was the team
coming to xbox and pc it was first
announced a decade ago that looks
exclusive
xbox and pc did they
just check it out
exclusively
that looks exclusive
you like that exclusivity
what's up everybody and what's up put
your shirt on man what is up
so sick and tired of black adam acting
up live streaming
i don't call him the rock no more yo
black adam put your shirt back on man
hey man he's coming at you he's done
pretty well for himself
yeah you own that gym too you ain't got
to go to work all day you can look like
that too plus you can go right down the
road because here in mexico they sell a
lot of you know you listen
number one no
i'm messing with you
you guys know me that's where the peds
is you know freely giving
is in his drinks
i'm glad he ain't showing nipple though
thank you man i appreciate the fact that
you don't want to show nip thank you i
appreciate it he just got out he just
got uh
out of the shower to look like he just
worked out
yeah right
uh
you guys also know he's like after this
i'm gonna i'm gonna probably you know
curl the house electrifying you know
maybe bench presses
listen i'm not gonna bother him because
he was diligent on getting blocked out
of him
and i'm so happy that uh they they cast
right i think the cash right because
black adam is one of my
favorite uh epic anti-heroes uh the
team's over there
because i love shazam
you know who else is a big gamer
is this funny how you just mentioned
the two guys that has like probably the
biggest standing beef in hollywood
there's a few differences
they have issues with each other
superman this is magic
one of his huge thing is magic
so you do the math uh october 21st i
cannot wait for you guys to see black
adam around the world that's right
and you guys will finally see the
hierarchy of power in the dc universe
exchange when she grabbed superman by
his throat thrown to the moon become
black adam and it was a
it is a role that's in my dna and that i
was born to play i was born i believe so
i believe so right to show it to you
guys on october 21st i cannot wait to
talk about that movie sir
on a large minute stay safe
stay focused
keep having fun keep picking up
uh enjoy your gaming he took cog spot
he said
what have your powers ever given to you
as before they gave him the hgh bath
until i died so you're gonna take this
hch you're gonna get in the pit i was
reborn to god
so what did he give him
isn't that
cannot wait for him to grab superman up
by his throat get him
up to you
no he can beat superman
superman is allergic to magic
oh he's magic magic
that's why superman can't beat shazam
unless uh you know
i highly recommend the comic book
kingdom come
oh beautiful story
[Music]
what's this
all right yes baby
august you know me
it's me
i can't i'll wait for this
i know the dlc is not gonna be in game
pass but the game is still in there
and this is one of the games that um i
really like playing outside of destiny
it's it's it's fun even in this broken
state that we had it in it was it was so
much fun it was tremendous fun
and i'm glad that you know game pass
gave it a good light
that they were able to get to this uh
dlc
because i don't think so i don't think
without game pass it doesn't make it it
doesn't get to this light
[Applause]
you never got really um all into
outriders right
not really i wasn't really like fighting
with it a whole lot
i got all into the lore of it
it was good the move sets the way that
you build your character and spec your
character out it was so good it looks
like it's like one of the only
games to really give destiny's community
a run for its money
yeah they stood by it man
they didn't let it die
hmm
[Music]
platoon three
oh
monster hunter rise
oh cuphead making it over there
yes
[Music]
play your way
jeff asked him well nintendo do you want
to participate there like just give him
the one we're playing on youtube next
week
oh what is it oh the fall guys here
you know this comes out like
in a week and a half on xbox right
yep and we get a chance to play
valkyrie
[Music]
i love when stuff organically grows
it's a good game i really enjoyed it
xbox series
that was so fun to see courage and ray
and that fall guys piece and you can
play and download fall guys for free
starting june 21st across all platforms
including nintendo switch xbox pc and
playstation all right back to another
new game announcement we're going to
announce a brand new game and universe
from a new team of legendary developers
check this out
let's see what we got here world
premiere yeah yeah
studios
ice climber too
i want to go there so i can go see the
northern lights
cross giant studio signal's breaking up
command i'll do one last scan see you
soon
okay hurry
nothing
[Music]
an rts studio
so everything we're seeing here is bull
guys cap huh
their website won't even load command
maybe on to something
because right now
everybody in the world did the same
thing that you just didn't
collapse they sight
[Music]
mission accomplished
anya six
that
she just said that she plays xbox and
now the playstation fanboys are after
put the shield up blast him
crota
hang tight doc i've got this
so what's that record too
that's
proton give me the soul stone so i can
come back
[Music]
oh
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
register
for 2023 vader
that you're gonna ain't coming out to
2025.
playstore
stormgate.com
world world premiere tim congratulations
is real we have a name and some details
uh so first of all congratulations on
this announcement we're so excited about
the return of rts how long is this thing
today franchise what is a storm game
all right so storm gates are portals
that open during a massive solar storm
wait a second unleash the infernal you
didn't bother to find out the whole run
time uh and we saw some hints of some i
mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone's know
about races uh you know
yeah we're unveiling our first two
factions today but there will be more uh
so the human resistance and we saw an
archaeologist from the human resistance
in that
intro cinematic and then also the
infernal hosts who are these routine is
in game one is in game pass day one
routine i think one thing everyone wants
to know about especially routine
background
where do you want to push the rts genre
it's something we've all loved for
decades but you know opportunity for a
lot of innovation
i know you're going to show us i think
some some hints of where you're going to
go image-wise with the actual gameplay
made in unreal engine but any sense of
what you want to do for the game play in
this game
absolutely but the first thing i want to
say is we are very consciously trying to
stay true to what players already love
about rts um
where we're really trying to push the
genre
he wants to do real-time strategy but
approachability what we need to see is
the orientation of the game no pay to
win no nfts nothing like that um just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three player open-ended co-op
um and we've even got three versions is
that day one sir because a lot of games
have been shipping without certain also
still got one needed and as a little
promise
work in progress just to be released at
a later date yeah these are still you
know very much still they're not happy
there's not enough day one game pass in
this actual assets
i mean
i'm looking with discerning eyes
see this is what i'm talking about now
you see exactly how the game looks are
you going to be playing from that
top-down perspective
blizzard and starcraft we're so excited
about that the gears game um
announcement today on summer game fast
what's the halo game halo
all right frosh giants
now it's time for another indie game
announcement that i'm excited to share
with you high water check this one out
high water
world premiere mayor mayor maryland
high water pirate radio keeping you in
the know with our flow
alphaville authorities continue to deny
false rumors all elites are planning to
evacuate to mars true or not the one
thing we can't deny
what's the the one he looks like a
cartoon
[Music]
i don't know
yeah you know which zelda i'm talking
about oh um
man it would look crazy if it was done
like this i mean like leak to the past
looks really good but
with
oh look at that that looks nice
looks like something on the switch
there's nothing wrong with that
i beg to differ because you know the
water reflections and
from certain things
it definitely looks 30 frames
yeah it doesn't look like a lens to the
switch though
i mean it
switch can handle certain things but
certain aspects of this it looks really
really
artsy and good
[Music]
well we'll see
come in 2022
for later this year
what a breathtaking trailer high water
is an adventure strategy game set in a
world ravaged by extreme climate change
now speaking of the world around us the
conflict in ukraine is not far from
anyone's mind and it's impacted the
development of games including replaced
from sad cat studios a belarusian studio
with devs from belarus and ukraine the
team had long hoped to reveal a new
trailer here today but we're
understandably unable to complete it in
time guys i just want to say we're
thinking of you and all the developers
impacted by the conflict we hope to be
able to share your work at a future show
all right our next game is an official
selection of the tribeca games festival
it's american arcadia where you play
trevor whose life is being televised
with the viewing population constantly
voting you up or down when you become
unpopular
you need to start running for your life
check this out
say running for your life world premiere
american arcadia
where technology and science go hand in
hand with fun and entertainment the man
your nose where is your nose
elijah walton had a dream to build the
city i had a dream because i know that
is now a reality and that city is
arcadia
a 43 square mile metropolis where each
and every citizen enjoys a life of
luxury and comfort
broadcasting what is the game 24 hours a
day seven days a week on every digital
platform
american
uh
what's the game tapioca
subject on the run on camera 4025
interrupt broadcast immediately
no haha yeah
okay
oh i'm about this
yeah yo they got a lot of flashback
stuff coming back here i like this allow
trevor hills to escape under any
circumstances trevor hills trevor
trevor can you hear me
be careful what you want to do
don't worry
i'm going to get you out of there
i would have preferred a little bit more
like explaining on the features we've
made it to the beach there you go next
up is a sequel we've all been
anticipating for a long time there's
trouble in paradise and watch out you
don't want to get bitten after many
years of rumors we finally get an update
on this much anticipated sequel
[Music]
world world world premiere
epic game oh game store epic game store
oh
dying light 2
no no no dead island two yeah
[Music]
they're gonna do the pain where it goes
bad and people are starting to eat each
other again didn't they already do this
trailer no
oh no this isn't that
no
[Music]
they literally ripped off the um
the other trailer
gold simulator
three
oh my god i was so excited for a brief
moment
i just got in my saber tooth magneto and
apocalypse civilizations heroes from the
avengers and x-men cross over with
supernatural ones like blade and ghost
rider for a battle against lilith the
mother of demons today we've got a look
at some new folks set to join the battle
[Music]
wake up
under your master published courtesy of
metallica yes
you know what's crazy
the one time i would be okay with a
developer injury after this watch there
not be one
venom
venom was part of this fruit
oh midnight son no yeah
is he a bad guy
who's in him yeah
venom is an anti-hero but um
midnight sun rain ain't even part of the
midnight sun
you know they
gonna be very liberal with uh
it's fine
oh
[Music]
typical parker luck
i'm gonna need some
backup was spider-man part of the
midnight zone no
is that ghost rider yes sir but there's
nothing
huh
yeah this yes
some random ghost rider that's probably
the the robbie rodriguez ghost rider
i'm more of a danny catcher
i had to mute the the stream for a
couple seconds guys because of the music
oh
oh that's cool october 7th
oh preorder now and get the doctor frank
dr strange defender skin
yo he wore that outfit not a lot
counting on you again old friend
three
two
one
[Music]
that used to always work well it did
that one time
can you believe it we're only a couple
weeks away from playing the delicious
last course dlc you see how they did
that for cuphead joining me now
people are waiting
hr so first of all
it's really coming
it's really coming june 30th on all
major platforms we are thrilled well i'm
so thrilled too that uh i think all the
fans can't know who's
and i've been lucky enough to play this
actually on my steam deck uh last week
you guys gave me a couple yeah we gotta
we gotta hit up uh cuphead uh producers
get a little man put in the game
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult i
think the little man looks dope in there
look you guys have taken it even to the
next level i didn't think it was
possible because her shirt is black and
white so little man go great well really
honed our craft took everything to the
next level from animation the
backgrounds the music gameplay design
uh i spoke to that developer man
i'm very proud of you nausea you know
jealousy is fun to play as and and even
though this is explaining all the stuff
inside of cuphead in many ways it is it
is definitely yeah you just get on the
island and there you are off to this new
uh new territory which is yeah it's our
biggest island yet super sized bosses
lots of secrets to discover um don't let
any rock go unturned
yes and lots of challenge ahead well i
know you brought i know you want you
don't want people to necessarily have
too much spoiled about the game but you
brought a little something a little
something yeah it's a brand new gameplay
footage of one of our new bosses
mortimer freeze it takes place in an icy
arena
and features some of my personal
favorite attacks and transformations we
hope everyone enjoys it all right let's
check it out cuphead delicious last
course
[Music]
oh
the ice cube
oh my god that looks so good
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
i like it with i leave
out his head
oh
popped his super because he makes you
invincible for a couple seconds
he
oh and he got the knockout oh the
eyeballs gonna catch him that dude is
nice whoever was playing right there is
definitely nice
not a lot of money if you want even more
cuphead and who doesn't tomorrow we will
show you an exclusive look at season two
of the cuphead show when i co-host
netflix's geeked week which will include
new shows
it streams at 10 a.m pacific
eastern
and that's not all there's more summer
game fest all weekend long coming up
next is the day of the devs indie
showcase with i am 8bit and double fine
then devolvers marketing they really end
up targeting
tomorrow after geek week there is the
epic game store showcase at 11 a.m
pacific 2 p.m eastern with news on
rocket league and the tribeca game
showcase and sunday don't miss the xbox
and bethesda game showcase not me uh
streaming all of that stuff
now we have some exciting news for
nintendo switch and pc fans about neon
white a game where you play an assassin
from hell who slays
demons have 400 and some people in the
chat let's get those likes up share that
out [__] that out
why are they saying i'm not signed in
that's so stupid we're called neons
sinners plucked from hell to do god's
dirty work oh cause i'm finding it hard
to believe we're inhabited
uh
i look kind of nice though
june the 16th
unique art style don't think it's for me
single father in poland
over the past year
to bring his vision for a fast-paced
action game midnight fight festival is
coming out let's take a look june 16th
i'm watching this slow i've been cut the
stream
you exited the stream yes
why do you think i was talking about old
stuff
i thought he was like okay yeah tomorrow
and such and such day head yeah
not him me
well i ain't wearing it anymore and
neither are you
tonight we washed this whole damn
suck game looks nice though
such a cool game i'm happy to announce
that a pc demo of this game is going
live right now on steam and will be part
of the steam next fest next week i
really want more playable games all
right
all right joining me now is megan from
digital extremes to talk all things
warframe megan how you doing i'm so good
my fellow canadians i know we got like
oh that's awesome these canadian teams
on the show i don't know how that works
out right okay we do well we have a
great connection we've also done a lot
with warframe over the years and i know
right now anyone watching on twitch for
more than 30 minutes this show is going
to get a special twitch drop right
that's right i already have seen people
getting it so it's very exciting she's
right there loud and proud protea 30
minutes for
watching thing on the next your special
events category but she is there and she
is anybody remember that movie i forgot
what it was called i said we've done a
lot of
you guys have done incredible things
with the game and i know
in
but yeah july 16th 2022 it's a digital
event character's helmet is not today no
bueno just launched the digital items
for it so you can get some in-game
goodies some really cool cosmetics some
merch all that really great stuff went
live today but of course the reason i'm
here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and that's an
infinity gauntlet that do guy in the
background play a little bit of a demo
and i think a lot of people can suspect
what it might be but i'm here to kind of
confirm what it is that tunnel live is
going to show
and what is that
can i say that okay you're gonna get
your first look at the daviri paradox
finally finally i know i know it's been
a couple of years uh but davier paradox
is gonna be what tenno live is all about
and i'm so happy uh the team worked
really hard on the teaser i got to do
the raid and i'm just really proud and
excited to show it awesome well thanks
so much for being here on summer game
fest let's take a look at that right now
world premiere mirror mirror my child
my friend oh craig face
[Music]
no no no not like this choices await us
now
are they using the dude face that plays
the mandalorian
they just got a sick reflection they put
him in a circus mirror
[Music]
for now
dream of who we were
and of who we have
[Music]
the become
paradox
should i do well to show our single
world
only the world don't know
[Music]
and you can get this suit
that sword looks nice but it's a gun
or is it a sword
what a tassel or is it a fan
it's keys
i'll get the man behind the mask
next it's time for a new look at hong
kong star rail an upcoming open world
space rpg yeah a lot of space today from
gentian impact studio hoya versus a lot
of space today because i don't have
stars
and this new trailer reveals for the
very first time a new and exotic realm
players will be able to explore
he got star rail not star phil
[Laughter]
he got starfield step brother star real
you know somebody like but it looks
better starfield king
[Laughter]
you are in a daze right now
you don't know
you know this reminds me of um
what's that game star what um
in the near future it's is it like a
like a it's not a mmo
yeah it's an
star ocean
yep that's what it looks like it looks
like star ocean
i wonder if it's in the same universe
[Music]
that's the you i like
oh
don't let them get close up on you b
she released something
i have wine to soothe the souls of
honored guests
welcome aboard the ciao
cyberpunk 20 20 20 20 20.
world premiere that's not all from
hoyoverse today i'm excited to introduce
you to zenless zone zero their next
major new ip it's a futuristic urban
action game i have to say i'm blown away
by what i've seen so far it was
announced a couple weeks ago and it has
the detail of gentian impact with a
fast-paced action style here is the
world premiere of a brand new look at
zenless's notable characters armed
enemies and world of danger
let's get it
another world premiere mirror mirror
holy verse
i'm the girl with the little cat ears
no no no no fat dude the gun
nah nah nah i'm the dude with the sword
right there the girl with the sword
nah that wolf dude i don't know they got
a lot of guys i like
that's the character you have to play
with
showed you 20 cool characters and made
you play with her
that looked kind of good
what the hell
just when you thought you know someone
eh
i didn't really yeah i get a chance to
be the fat dude impact a whole lot
either
did it come on gay path no it's not even
on xbox doesn't mean
what is this
i don't know
world premiere that's what it is
shredders revenge which reminds us all
of the turtles arcade games back in the
day well it's nearing the end of
development all those foot soldiers
and they could not beat four turtles
i'll be mad as hell too keeping under
wraps until now
[Music]
it's out right now in game pass stop
playing right now
casey jones they didn't show that we
didn't see casey jones until right now
[Music]
so don't be mad at me i wasn't able to
capture casey jones footage because why
it was giving it to jeff
[Music]
this is going to be so much fun
play this game while eating some gummy
bears
yeah
gummy bears or flavor
well i get the soda pack
leave my mango gummy bears alone
[Music]
hello yeah that was one of my best games
at pax
who's available
june 16th oh
live and game pass
you wish your game look like that
it's a battlefield
next gen update
[Music]
i have absolutely no idea sir
i don't think it's any road though
[Applause]
[Music]
they're going after the fortnite books
that were stolen from them you're going
to pay with yourself
super people how do you have a final
data because that's debated right before
they release it so it's finally
the final beta oh
it looks like a civilization
i get the chance to play god again
in the inca territory
yet no doubt argentinians you will feel
the raft
cubans you will fill the wrath
all latin american cultures you will
feel the wrath of humanity
[Music]
it's a wrap son
but wait there's more
off
the perfect game pass
read white history
those people that you called winners
consumed do you losers
and those losers that you call losers
would soon be winners is this a game
faster
[Music]
huh
or something
gorgeous
no
how fast
it's your story
[Music]
humankind
that looks interesting
gameplay
by combining a multitude of historical
civilizations from the ancient to the
modern era they're looking good i would
actually i'm actually probably just
celebrating oh this is what i'd like to
see this is turn based and bandai namco
is bringing the mega popular franchise
back to video games with one piece
odyssey monkey to luffy and his crew of
pirates are off on their next adventure
this trailer reveals the setting a
mysterious island where luffy and his
straw hat crew become marooned in this
exciting upcoming jrpg
[Music]
let it be dubbed
friday
they're gonna show a little bit of the
gameplay
are we just doing the cgi
us you just blew some of these minds
like that is gameplay
that is gay plea addict oh no did you
fight six
arms zoro
[Applause]
no
that looks nice
and hidden mysteries
[Music]
supposed to be a turn-based game
odyssey
world
this august soul hackers 2 from
listen to the english voice cast with
this quick new look
what is this the english voice cast
this is a turn-based game too
ringo this is like one of the first
atlas games to come to uh
what is the one that's talking about
yeah
when this comes out might have to review
it
[Music]
cool
take my hand better you than me sir
better you than me
[Music]
you get one more chance to make things
i think this might be a game pass day
with so many new games featured across
sgf and you might be wondering how to
plan for your summer gaming dreams nerd
wallet can help you find the smartest
credit card to reward your gaming
purchases
he hasn't really gave us an epic mega
sale is going on right now save up to
seventy-five percent mega sales two
titles with an additional 25 off
eligible products and it wouldn't be the
mega sale without the free games vault
featuring man eater be sure to claim
your copy before the sale ends on june
16th
tune in to the epic game store twitter
for our summer showcase on june 10th at
2 p.m eastern 11 a.m pacific we're
taking a look at new announcements and
updates from pc titles heading to the
store this year and beyond
[Applause]
what if all your games is in one place
what do you mean
what if you could just hit an app
and you can play game pass xbox
and playstation all over
the tv
samsung gaming hub
my samsung tv in the living room about
to get a bitter deuce
audio for each game
start playing hockey
actually
i've i've been trying out the uh
streaming services on the pc
i mean on xbox it actually works pretty
good
yeah
samsung's gaming hub
[Music]
wrestling
[Laughter]
in mario striker's battle league in this
no holds bark soccer-ish sport chaos
reigns supreme so prepare for how much
uh nintendo paid
so much fun it hurts
mario striker's battle league only on
nintendo switch game rated everyone 10
and up
[Music]
hi my name is carl and i'm a developer
and metal hell singer you know how in
some games with the music's really good
you feel compelled to move and shoot to
the beat but what if you had to in metal
the better you are at slaying to the
beat the more intense everything gets
and we have vocal performances from
legendary artists like serge thank you
from system of a down so while
headbanging isn't mandatory we do
recommend it our demo is live now on
steam xbox and playstation platforms so
go check it out and slay to the beat
it says outsiders on his shirt
it might have been the studio name
yeah
looks like doom
was so successful along with quaking
them that
um
every game was you know mimicking them
i'm sure
my cousin people they'd like this
[Music]
[Applause]
systems of the down
straight to sleepovers
i thought you'd look nice
you're able to switch off the katana
[Music]
[Applause]
like it does look like doing some
aspects where they have some cool stuff
metal hell singer
demo out now behind the pay wall on the
playstation 5.
you're ridiculous
metal hellsinger coming later this year
from funcom a rhythm shooter with metal
music and right now as i mentioned a
demo has launched on pc xbox and
playstation for you to play for free
next up a new game launches tomorrow the
quarry from super massive games this
spirit yeah i tried my hardest to get a
review for that cat and an all-star cast
it's getting great reviews and this is
one of those binge-worthy teen horror
entertainment experiences where your
every choice shapes your story and
determines who lives and who dies at a
camp in upstate new york here's the
first look at the launch might just go
ahead and pick it up and
you know
yeah
but if your whole family i've did a
review in like three weeks
every last one of them decided to jump
down the bottom of a well they're all
just i gotta drop the new kos hanging on
the end removing all the stuff and doing
all these unboxings
[Music]
she pulling that rope i'm just gonna
fall right down the bottom of the well
with the rest of it
and what's the point of that
what
there is a lot more to this than you
realize
like what
kidnapping murder cover-ups i think the
whole packet family is in on it
you have no idea what's going on here
got a goddamn clue
oh this is the quarry game yeah i tried
my hardest to get a review for this man
i even got someone in 2k should i call
911. you mean 9-1-1 who says 91-1
wow
they got a lot of the faces of the
actors and actresses
i love that old lady
she comes from everything that uh
you're gonna laugh at she's very good
coming right up
i got the ketchup
all right i'm refreshing the string guys
five
were proud to reveal nightingale a
shared world survival crafting game from
inflection games up in canada
what's up man how are you going man
including its innovative realm card
system that lets you impact things like
the weather pattern resources and
challenges in its procedural realms here
is your exclusive new look
[Music]
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a mess
not even sure if nightingale made it
given how fragile you humans are
oh
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources
once you have realm cards you can
activate the portal
beware
now things lurk in the interim
void waiting to get in
be ready
no goon i don't have ad blocker on my pc
i don't mind ads
[Music]
yo i mean if this game actually really
wow
it's a very unique idea
[Music]
if these shadows have offended
think about this
oh no no
don't lie you love that uh
thing of armor just chilling there
behind you now my face like that
tighten a little box
see lincoln box face king are marching
in on august 23rd with the title there
you go this is what she was asking for
at gamescom and today we're having this
thing
[Music]
you guys are going to have a lot of fun
with this one check it out
it got some stuff in it that i like
oh man i can't wait
yeah i see i saw this one to capture
so what do we build next
yeah they got a whole flight suit and
all that
you can't customize your character
that's your fault
heavy on customization
[Music]
dinner and a show baby
yo
that's cool
they showing right now you can't make
yourself that's your fault it's your
fault that's what i said
yo
vladimir
i love this
oh
johnny
[Applause]
i think this game is going to do well
it always does well right before uh
grand theft auto comes out then grant
that photo comes out smashes it
download now
oh
free on playstation 5 and 4 xbox series
x and x let's get it
it's behind that paywall a demo
next we've got an exclusive first look
oh warhammer
hammer 40k dark tie fat sharks follow up
to the critically acclaimed vermintide
series dark tide promises intense
four-player co-op action and terrifying
enemy hordes to team up against and it's
our out on september 13th for pc on
steam and exclusively on console on xbox
[Music]
world premiere
exclusive on your xbox
systems
so you're going to restore the colony
safe today
[Music]
and use the cryonic rods to flush the
system
preferably before something explodes
you're mad he's too big for the screen
that nobody knows anything
that's a big voice
this way move it
yes
yeah i got to use big boy because he got
that gun though
oh
it looks impressive though
oh that was when it was running on the
[Music]
part series
get to the base of the matrix fire and
put those cryonic rods to work
[Applause]
oh you saw him gather the energy in his
head
slam it into the box pause
get that hammer
oh your man look like the rhino
september 13th
game pass looks like it's very healthy
for the rest of the
[Music]
today they are ready to reveal their
latest creation made completely in
unreal engine 5 for a visceral is this
silence no that's what they've been to
return to the world of layers of fears
of this
[Music]
here we go world premiere someone once
said blair's affair
let it
run
it's done in unreal engine
yo
all right you already know i like luba
team's work that's crazy
watch the eyes move
uh
smack the hell out that picture
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i walk into a house and
there's nothing but chains my ass is
turning right around and leafy
look at that ray tracer this looks good
did that old lady just rip off that
little kid's head all this suffering the
ends and stuff like that blueberry team
definitely wicked when it comes to stuff
like that
they like to give me the kids
beautiful
someone said horde unreal five oh hell
no
that's right my non-real engine 5 for
those who are
the uneducated that comes after four
[Laughter]
get in the water
you're gonna walk the plank
you're blowing me
all i did was steal some rice
like more than your rations get off the
board
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo look how it shifted into space
is there different levels to being white
huh is it like yes it is is there like a
mortal combat thing where you go up up
and up
like yo it's certain white that you walk
in you go
you know it's hello i was playing uh
south park fractured butthole last night
and the difficulties depending on how
black you are
like if if if it's on the hardest
difficulty
you're you're black black like you get
lighter the farther you go back
that's ridiculous that's so racist
thrilled to share more with you on one
of our beloved nights nightwing
this showcase is the first in our
character series
as we continue working towards our
launch on october 25th
so i hope you enjoyed the show and stay
tuned
the bat
the bird
the cat nightwing
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
dance on
i think batman is um faking his death
just to see who's gonna step up
once a batman's the last boss
yeah i found that to be really matter
how hard we try
there's always more to do
and now
it's up to me
i like that they keep showing different
outfits so they let you know that you
can get different outfits
i wonder if they just cause medical or
do they have any um real significance
i got this bruce
how's our nightwing in a robin i thought
they're the same person well no cause uh
damian wayne's is bruce wayne's son
uh dick grayson is nightwing
from naughty dog
oh naughty dog
an eventful day on the internet for
naughty dog fans and uh i think we
jinxed ourselves yeah we're joking about
tell the story
tell the truth shane the devil let them
know they're gonna play for the next
game that they remade again
over again for another 70 people about
all things at naughty dog but first of
all it is a
big month actually for last dos fans
because uh last of us one and two both
launched in june and it's nearing its
two-year anniversary for last of us uh
part two which is hard to hard to
believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one it's
technically called now last night and we
still hear from fans they're still
sending us letters and art and these
characters in this journey in this world
mean so much to them
um
it's it's just been kind of amazing like
last was part two early this year passed
a pretty big milestone and sold over 10
million units i hope they don't end the
show with this success um we're so
grateful to our fans it has allowed us
to grow as a studio and now we can take
on multiple projects more than we've
ever had at the same time
multiple projects okay very interesting
so uh what can last us last of us fans
expect in the future from you thank you
for asking jeff
so one of the things we've mentioned a
while back is what started out as a
multiplayer mode has evolved due to the
team's ambition they really wanted to do
something beyond what we've ever done
before at naughty dog and we felt the
way to do it justice is to make it a
standalone title and over they've been
working on it for the past two years
thank you it's grown and we're not quite
ready to oh my god we're gonna lift the
curtain a little bit and just give you
like an update of where we're at
okay well uh what can you tell us about
this new standalone multiplayer game
yeah so uh we have a concept art that we
want to show um
concept what i can't tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single players
in some ways i actually feel like they
could do a battle royale really well
telling that story is very unique to
this game um it's got a brand new cast
of characters it takes place at another
place another part of the united states
like a city might somewhat familiar some
people i'm sure our fans have already
figured it out um
uh and it's it's really cool and it's
being headed by vineeth uggerwall um
anthony newman and uh joe pannady all
veterans of uncharted and last of us and
you're gonna see a lot more of this game
come next year
next year so i wait till next year to
hear more about that one okay well very
exciting that uh this has evolved and i
mean that concept art looks incredible i
can't wait to see naughty dog
storytelling fused with multiplayer live
game uh it's it's something special we
can't wait to show it either okay well
um that's not all we also have something
that i've been reading about on the
internet every day it feels like up in
calgary they're filming the last of us
show for hbo right
yeah so uh
this year um playstation
production hbo yeah they made it
they made a division called playstation
productions is that was that before this
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting back when we're looking at back
at nollie dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
and the quality is so high
it's so authentic to what we've made in
the game
um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there
and they're actually their last day of
filming is tomorrow so the entire series
last day of filming they are filming us
tomorrow craig is up there right now
kind of wrapping it all up uh so it's
it's pretty close it's closer than you
might think and you actually got to
direct one of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode i actually directed oh um first
look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game um and i really have to talk about
pedro pascal and bella ramsey and not
only directing them but seeing them do
all the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles for a whole
year
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game um
and it really feels like this is going
to be
something special and i will say this
will be the most authentic video game
adaptation yet well i mean that first
image that they put out it just i mean
it feels like the video game everything
that i've seen both public and other
stuff makes it feel sort of super
legitimate you said and that's awesome
to see uh julian ellie from from the
front side now for the first time um so
we'll see more of that next year that's
coming as well right seriously uh you'll
hear about it very soon that's okay i'll
say right now all right well last of us
hbo very very exciting uh and i hear you
actually have a couple actors from the
show who are going to join us you happen
to have a couple actors here that are
part of the show we should bring them up
okay come on
oh what's up guys oh hello
surprise troy's back again hello good to
see you good to see you uh i'm a little
confused though i thought maybe pedro
bella but troy asher out here uh from
the game right so uh when craig and i
started working on the show almost one
of our very first meetings we said troy
and ashley have to be a part of it um
and we're such fans of like the talent
and the help like helping us create joel
and ellie um we felt like it was so
important that they become part of the
show and it wasn't it's it has to be
more than just like kind of like a wink
to the camera and like a cameo yeah
these are real roles that we're keeping
on the road now he's going into uh but
man i was all the guys back with the no
socks there's been so much
the internet there's so much like talk
about what's being filmed and i think
that's you guys have kept a complete
secret that you so you were up there and
you filmed your roles by now obviously
keeping secrets with this franchise is
kind of old hat like we've had for today
except for the date uh it was it was one
of the hardest things for us to do is to
let not let people know that because
we're so proud of it and the work that
we did we worked hard the crew i have to
say um when i walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew uh is such a fan
of this game and they all
knew what it was that they were working
on and committed to working on this
project because of their fan and their
love for the for the game uh was one of
the greatest it was like i was coming
home to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good
it's it's i love the story i love just
being a part of it i'm so excited
about series and the fact that you guys
are gonna be in it and undisclosed i'm
so fascinated how it's gonna sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
i can tell you so sneaky all right well
we're so excited maybe it's already on
twitter
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give people the
definitive version of the first game
that wasn't encumbered by any technology
i wanted to find a way to get even
closer to our original vision and we're
able to do it on the ps5
and pc and instead of talking about it
let's look at it all right let's see
last of us
yes sir
day and day
i don't know if it'll be a date no no no
no no no no i'm gonna send you something
right
bc day today i will send you something
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little
girl 9 22. you know
i've never been this close looks
beautiful
it's the outside
so is that everything you hoped for
exactly he's going to lose his [__] over
this
got a super chat from uh fiesta double
oh seven king hope you and the family
oh thank you so much brother once upon a
time
i had somebody that i cared about
and in this world that's good for one
thing this looks really good get you
killed i mean what are your different
gameplay things i can take care of
myself how many close calls are rebuilt
from the ground up for the playstation
5. i get in trouble you know what i i
might ever i might get it
you know played on your playstation 5
you know
built all the way up you know part one i
really love part two more than anything
truly one of my favorite games it is
just booking my partner reaction to that
yeah we haven't seen that yet yeah
you're watching it in real time
uh
i mean part one was really good but i
wasn't
as emotionally invested in it uh as i
was in part two part two
here just how much it has changed wow we
did the models and we built everything
everything was rebuilt from you know you
see that the same art director yeah
it's impressing from the ground up um
you got my money look at the window and
we could have achieved before through
the walls um and that's just like one of
those things
yeah you know what i i think i got to go
upstairs
log into my playstation to get my life
back
let them give me back my damn account
they're all only players ps5 and pc yeah
we wanted them to have the definition yo
tell me why i called playstation the
other day right and i called them at two
o'clock in the afternoon
why did they say well call us your
normal business hours and i'm like what
to refresh my memory before because i
was trying to um recover my account um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally yeah and you cried like a damn
baby anniversary of part two coming out
so i mean it looks like i'm definitely
going to be up for another year i mean
yeah i can't wait to go back oh i can't
yeah i'll i'll get that i'll get that i
love i love everything about it
system the new ai system everything
we've learned on like untreaded four
last of us two we applied to this again
to give that definitive version just to
give a quick shout out who did this this
was a shadow studio that did this right
and shauna skye okay uh and you'll hear
a lot more about and see a lot more
about over the coming weeks leading up
to this you don't remember when they had
that uh the the uh shortly thereafter
the deep studio that they have working
in the background games directed by
other people what what are you doing and
they wanted to do their own game but
they hadn't worked on a lot of people's
time i haven't given up my my day job
uh
it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in places wants to leak
it then we can talk about it
otherwise uh we'll save it you do have a
new project do you have a new project uh
but we'll save it for another summer
game fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys appreciate it thanks jeff
awesome
all right well that is gonna do it
thanks to naughty dog and playstation
for that very special uh look at the
last of us and the entire franchise and
where things are going good way to end
the show
sorry your joint was leaked early
so they took the win out of your sales
job
and double fine including an exclusive
new look at the planet atlanta and then
the devolver digital showcase tomorrow
we've got netflix geeked week which i'll
be co-hosting and the tribeca game
showcase streaming
no way you got me on tomorrow and
finally sunday it's the xbox and
bethesda game showcase you can stream
them all at
summergamefest.com as for me i'll see
you again in august when we are back
live in cologne germany for gamescom
opening night live on august 23rd and
then the game awards will return in
december live i don't know why i thought
germany was finally i'm excited to share
that summer game that's september in
june 2023 as a digital in-person event
to bring the gaming community together
thanks for being a part of summer game
fast
there's no way
we'll see you soon
for my birthday
what
oh the
game's gone
no you think summer game show is gonna
be uh
next year it's gonna be in person yeah
yeah i know that i'm talking about um
he's talking about gamescom i'm gonna
talk about what i was talking to toby
about wow
oh okay
all right guys so we are just me and him
no i don't have my camera on today uh
so we're gonna talk about how you felt
about the show
um
hey guys uh put a one in the chat if it
was a decent show put a two in the chat
if it was trash
i i i thought i i thought for myself um
i thought
you know i
i thought for myself i thought it was
pretty good i thought it was a pretty
good show
um i didn't i didn't think that i would
get uh
the
the last of us part one
honestly
but it looked really good um they put
time into that but the question is
is that worth seventy dollars
yeah i i
you know my hard to oppose the the ten
dollars luxury tax that they put on you
but um
it doesn't look it look it's it's not
using old assets shined up uh
it's using uh it's already built from
the ground up so
i want to see how it plays but
from a visual perspective
it looks phenomenal it looks uh
fantastic
so um
i i'm i'm going to give it a look uh
because i i respect that franchise so
much that's probably my number one
franchise that's on the playstation at
the moment
um and does that take does the you know
because certain games got pushed back to
next year but the show overall
uh looked really good they had a lot of
stuff that was on steam a lot of stuff
that's out you know right now a lot of a
lot of good stuff was shown
uh i got to give a shout out to jeff for
keeping that uh e3 feeling going
you
you want to respect this week this week
is kind of holy for us gamers so all
information that we can get out is a
fantastic thing i think he did a real
good job in that and then he's gonna
have more stuff tomorrow and he's gonna
have more stuff to lead up so shout out
to him for keeping that light on like a
motel six man uh it's nothing but
respect and fan service to the gamers
man and somebody let's get let's let's
uh get those uh get that stuff out of
the chat mods
let's get that stuff out of there
we don't need them you know i think
i think it was a good show uh would i
prefer a little bit more gameplay on
like midnight suns yeah
um
you know it's interesting god of war
wasn't here now i'm really starting to
to double down on that gamestop coming
out well i told you it wasn't coming out
anyway so
yeah and i was right there with you but
when
i felt like they're being a little bit
too
too open with it you know what i'm
saying so
but now i'm starting to be there with
you i think it is it is coming it is not
coming out this year well i think we
would have seen something at this event
we just didn't stay to play like
there's been plenty of opportunities to
show us something and then this is still
happening well if it comes out in march
it um it starts off the year good you
know so
i don't care but you guys know when i
take off my jewelry what time it is it's
over
but uh we we will see you guys sunday uh
i will be going live once again doing
another community spotlight uh sunday
it'd be the last one i'm not doing
another one after that
but another community spotlight got
new people doing it hope you guys like
it yeah
we will see
probably go live like 30 40
minutes early we'll see but i appreciate
it for coming through saturday combat
talk with the king see y'all saturday
night at 10 p.m
10 p.m
great fight remember
drinks on me first 200 people and get
free drinks
but i appreciate everyone coming through
man like i said i thought it was a good
show i thought they had a variety of
multiple stuff it could have been a
little bit more stuff that i would have
particularly liked but i can't deny
uh he did bring a lot of diversity in
terms of gameplay in different genres uh
so that that's nice and that uh but you
know like i said sunday
we'll be live streaming the xbox event
show up you guys know the best place to
react is with the lords
if they mess up man i'ma chew them up
pause
all right but i appreciate you guys you
guys have a good day we will see you
sunday and my camera will be on sunday
peace